[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey guys when did you get in here how
you doing yeah well since you're here I
can tell you about my plans for world
domination
I am planning a bunch of trips for next
year to go to conventions all over the
world just pretty much anywhere that you
got me to go um I've got plans right now
to go to Germany for games Khan our
Gamescom sorry London for something or
other
Australia for maybe a pax down that way
even Canada for a few things um but if
you guys got suggestions of where you'd
like to see me all over the world like
anywhere even like if there's a Nigerian
comic-con just suggested to me now I
can't make any promises but I'll
definitely try to make it there now that
doesn't mean that I'm not gonna be the
staples in the states um I don't know if
anything on the East Coast I'm going to
but I'm definitely going to pax prime
and San Diego Comic Con which is a
staple um I go to San Diego because my
brother has a booth out there because of
the company that he works for red giant
and um I actually wanted to take a
second to thank them a red giant because
they have been really nice to me about
two years ago some of you know the first
comic-con that I went to was San Diego
comic-con and I was I was brought out
there by them because my brother was
going out and he asked for an extra
ticket for me and they gave me an
exhibitor badge which was just
ridiculously awesome because an
exhibitor badge let me show up earlier
and leave later I got to see everything
early I got to go bind the scenes and
just see everything gets set up and torn
down and it was amazing for me because
that comic-con when I had maybe two
thousand subs and couldn't do anything
for this company they were nice enough
to put up with my bullet here are a few
pictures of me acting dumb back in their
booth but they were just ridiculously
cool to me and and they supported me
even though I couldn't do anything for
them they were still supportive of me
and were able to give me this pass and
they did
again for me this year at comic-con and
I mean it's just really cool that they
did that and they even brought me out to
a dinner that my brother and some other
artists went to I was just there and it
was a fancy restaurant and I I just felt
like they were really really cool to me
even though I couldn't do anything to
them and after that comic-con I really
realized that you know I wanted to do
these charity livestreams immediately
after that you can see the v-log way
back when I said I want to do charity
livestreams it was the one where I come
back from comic-con it I am officially
back from comic-con and I have the swag
to prove it it's where I said it's right
there somewhere around here you can
probably see it right now I want my
channel to be big enough to make an
impact on the gaming community as a
whole but yeah so I feel like I haven't
thanked them I probably haven't even
mentioned them in any video of mine but
I've put links down in the description
of their Facebook page and their website
um they're really cool if you can just
go there facebook toss it alike and say
a comment that markiplier says thanks
just for what they've done to me because
you know they I don't think they
expected anything back from it
especially back then when I had nothing
so I mean now that I have over a million
subscribers it'd be really cool if you
guys help me thank them and also you can
check out their website too they've got
tons of free comics online like just
tons of them if you like comics and
maybe check one of them out other than
that just that'll be enough I think and
then I'll see them back in comic-con
again next year so that's good other
than that I've actually started up a
little hobby on my own I've started to
learn programming languages which is
really really hard back in high school I
took programming courses I think they
should have taught programming courses
alongside language courses but that's a
whole different thing but I'm trying to
learn Java and HTML and CSS and Ruby and
Python not as much but if you guys got I
suggest for a better way to learn then I
would love to hear it I'm trying up
codecademy and it's cool resource but
it's not as good as it's like taking a
course in it or learning from someone
directly so I mean the reason I'm doing
it of course I didn't even mention is
because I've really been
I've really been trying to embrace game
development itself and I want to be able
to kind of put my skills forward to
actually create something because let's
plays they're nice and all but they
don't add anything much to the gaming
community well they kind of do because
it promotes some small games but it
doesn't like this it's not what I want
to do with the rest of my life I want to
have these skills to be able to do these
amazingly creative things so I want to
learn so if there's a better way to
learn I would love to hear once again
put in the comments below what you got
for me to do alright also I've got some
secret projects that I'm not ready to
talk about just yet besides that it's
just been fantastic the support that you
guys have been giving me you guys
non-stop support now I've not stopped
grateful for what you guys have done to
me just thank you thank you generally
for everything I say that every v-log
but I always mean it what you guys have
done for me to change my life has been
tremendous I would never be in this
position where I could go all over the
world to see you guys at conventions
everywhere or get invited out to special
places and have these opportunities to
do these amazing things and you know
it's all thanks to you guys so sincerely
thank you for everything that you've
done to get me to this point just keep
it up you know go out there grab a
friend strapped into a chair force him
to subscribe go out to gaming forums go
out to anywhere on the internet go out
to your friends don't don't do that but
seriously if you guys keep it up just
get this one new subscriber you know
every once in a while that's fantastic
thank you guys so much for all your
support so that's about it leave a
comment where you want to see me in the
entire world once again no promises but
I will consider it
toss a thank you over to red giant make
sure you say that markiplier is saying
thanks maybe give some of their comics a
look-see it's pretty cool their small
company but hey maybe they'll be big
someday who knows and other than that
just generally thank you guys so much I
really do like doing these Monday V
likes to try to keep you guys up with
what's going on in my life so once again
thank you all so much for watching no
annotations to click don't worry
everything's out in the description hope
you have a lovely day and I will see you
does a little late in the next video bye
bye
[Music]
[Music]
Oh also I'm thinking about taking
singing lessons